欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这节课我们来讲一下关于产品的分组
怎么样去分组能够让买家有更好的体验
能够更快的找到他想要的产品给我们发寻盘
这样分组主要就是为了方便买家查找
重点突出产品的核心品类和爆品
首先我们在首页都可以看到大多数行业
所有的店铺都是会有这个产品的分类的是吧
那么我们分组一定不要超过两级分层
也就是这是第一层,这是第二层
你不要搞太多太多
比如说下面还有很多很多这种分组分组分组
非常不利于客户直接看到你的核心产品
也很难去查找
那么我们在这里分组的时候
第一个,第二个,第三个
这几个能够展示出来的
我们要把我们的核心品类排在前面
好的产品排在前面
分组内部的产品
也就是这个里面的产品
一定要把优质的产品提前展示在前面
这样的目的是什么呢
更方便我们客户找到我们的品类或者是款式
第二个就是能够让我们的爆款
有更多的曝光的机会
我们直接到后台来看一下
比如说我们刚才讲的
我们先去搜一个关键词
比如说搜一个关键词
随便点进来
点它的店铺
店铺里面看这里有个产品
看到吧
产品
像这样的话
我们如果还有很多产品
在这里排
还有很多产品在这里排的话
那么我们把无重要的放在下面这些
把能够展示的重要的放在前面这三个板块
前面这三个板块
你的核心主营内幕放在这三个板块
是最好的
因为客户点击你这里的时候
一般来说只会快速的流感到你前面的半部分的内幕
所以说你把越前面的越重要这个展示出来
比如说我点这里
点击点击点击出来之后
这里也要分类也要非常的简洁
这里的话
第二层的话要分类非常的简洁
这样的话
客户一看
就能够知道他要什么
然后客户点进来
比如说我点这个
进来之后
你的这里面的排版
这里面的产品的排版
这些一点
一点击一点击点击点击这些排版
就是这
这些排版你要把
好的产品
这些好的产品
全部往前排在这个前面
往前排在这个前面
理解吗
那么我们来后来看一下
首先在产品商品管理到
商品分组排序
那么我们看到的第一层是
对应的就是这一层
最外层的第一层就这一层
我们把它折叠打开
打开之后第二层就是这里的
第二层就是这里
我们这个板块呢
我们可以
把它移动
排序
比如说我们移动
你看
我鼠标一点住移动
移动
排它位置怎么排
排完之后呢
我们一定要保存
保存
保存了它才能够
固定在一个位置之后
比如说我这个产品
主内产品管理
点击进去之后
是不是这些
12345678910
排列的顺序
就是这里
点进去之后
排列的顺序
就这里里面
这个没有
他们没有产品
那么我们填这个
那么这里面12345678910
这样排列
就上到这个排列了
这样一路排下来
一路排下来
你看第一页
这样就是一路排下来
这里一路排下来
当然你还可以按照这个把它写成1
确定了之后他就跳转到第一页
第一个产品
这样的话你这里的话你就可以把你想要展示的那个产品展示在这个位置了
这样的话也可以排版
另外一个的话你还可以
这个产品的页面的话我们还可以去进行一个装修也就是我们看到的这个板块
下面还可以增加很多内容
在旺铺首页那里去装修这个页面也可以在这里增加内容
还可以在这里增加非常多的内容
比如说我在这里增加一个板块
这里增加
下面还增加几个板块
这些都是可以添加的在旺铺装修那里都可以添加
自定义设置的
那么这个内幕就是这样你把这些弄好了之后一定要记得保存保存完了之后刷新来这里去看
是不是你想要的牌序
以及
展示出来的产品是不是你想要让那些好的产品展示在前面按照这个逻辑去
一定要去
重视这个板块因为很多客户
点击首页进来的时候
他就是为了快速的找到产品你看
他点一个内幕就是为了能够更快的去
获得他的想要的信息
这个就是我们说的
产品的分组
排序
这个板块一定要重视起来
如果你的店铺现在还没有进行一个
比较
准确的分组
你可以现在去改善一下
那么分组我们通常按怎么来分呢?按照
客户的需求
或者按照你们公司品类的归属
这样分的话会更加清晰直观
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里